on est transexuel
on ne se fait pas opéré pour devenir
transexuel
s'il est une émission dans nos
actualités régionales qui n'a jamais
réclamé le carré blanc c'est bien
provençalement vôtre mais tout arrive et
ce soir je me dois de prévenir les
parents que la séquence qui va suivre
n'est pas destinée à leurs enfants
magiroubault il traitera d'un fait
divers récent qui a fait couler beaucoup
d'encre beaucoup trop peut-être dans une
certaine presse je parlais du problème
de la transexualité
alors pourquoi y revenir me direz-vous
et pourquoi si tard d'abord parce que
nous n'avons pas voulu traiter cette
affaire à chaud elle avait un goût de
scandale auquel nous sommes refusés à
céder et bien nous en a pris d'ailleurs
car une enquête fouillée nous a permis
de conclure que ceux ou celles qui se
trouvaient dans ce cas était davantage
des accidents de la nature voire
peut-être des erreurs chromosomiques que
des invertis que ceux qui les ont aidés
l'ont fait bien davantage par souci de
charité que par une espèce de déviation
mentale
et puis comme tous les Provençaux nous
commençons aussi à n'avoir assez de voir
Marseille ravaler au rang de Sodome
voire même de gomores que les Parisiens
qui nous critiquent si facilement
commence à regarder devant leur porte
ils y trouveront suffisamment de
turpitude à balayer et plus même sans
doute que sur notre trottoir voilà ce
que je voulais vous dire ce soir en
répétant aux parents que le
provençalement vôtre d'aujourd'hui
nécessite que soit éloignés des écrans
les jeunes oreilles et les jeunes yeux
je vous remercie de nous avoir prêté
attention
il faut pas avoir peur des mots vous
êtes des travestis je voudrais donc que
vous me disiez ce que représente ce mot
pour vous de travestir
une définition de ce que nous sommes
c'est un mot parce qu'il faut appeler
chaque chose par un an oui mais vous
savez que l'on vous appelle comme ça
alors comment le ressentez-vous en ce
qui me concerne
donc j'admets que j'accepte
[Musique]
on a dit beaucoup de choses trop
peut-être au sujet de cette affaire
aussi nous a-t-il paru souhaitable de
faire le point en quelques mots je vous
rappelle l'effet le 4 octobre dernier
était déposé dans un commissariat de
Marseille une plainte émanant de la mer
d'un adolescent de 16 ans qui se livrait
à la prostitution cette dernière accuse
le docteur Élise Salem d'avoir délivré à
son fils des ordonnances prescrivant des
injections d'hormones tendant à
féminiser son corps
qu'en est-il exactement les
prescriptions du Docteur Salem
tombe-t-elle sous le coup de la loi
sont-elles oui ou non dangereuses
ce dossier que nous ouvrons ce soir en
essayant d'y apporter le maximum
d'éléments nous l'avons surtout voulu
honnête
[Musique]
j'exerce dans un quartier où il y a des
travestis lorsqu'un travesti sonne à ma
porte je le reçois il m'est difficile de
fermer ma porte à qui que ce soit d'un
médecin se doit de recevoir tout être
humain qui a besoin de lui peut-être
sont-ils venus à vous aussi parce que
vous êtes une femme et me l'ont dit je
pense qu'ils viennent plus facilement
chez moi parce que je suis une femme je
précise que j'ai eu dans mes fichiers 12
dossiers de travestis cette investi
était déjà hormoné lorsqu'ils sont venus
vous voir
sans connaître l'existence des travestis
du carrousel de Paris et tout je pensais
déjà que peut-être un jour en mettant
des perruques en mettant des faux seins
pousser des cheveux je pourrais vivre
comme une femme
en fait vous aviez envie d'être une
femme
moi j'ai personnellement j'étais un
petit garçon mais je me suis toujours
senti une petite fille je joue à la
poupée avec ma sœur et tout
on compte actuellement en France 2500
travestis qui subissent à peu près tout
ce traitement hormonal
modifiant mon entraînement la
morphologie ce traitement peut-il être
considéré comme un délit
un délit dans la mesure où ces
injections
seraient néfastes à la santé oui
mais ça n'est pas mon point de vue
très rapidement éliminées
surtout lorsque le rythme n'est pas très
fréquent donc je sache et si ce sont de
très fortes doses ça dépend ce qu'on
appelle forte dose
il faudrait que ce soit des doses
surtout continues non pas seulement
fortes parce que le produit s'élimine
très rapidement en quelques jours il n'y
a plus rien or ce qui est dangereux
c'est la frénation que ces hormones
peuvent exercer sur l'hypophyse ce qui
ne semble pas être le cas
[Musique]
ces injections
ne modifie donc en rien le processus
normal sauf pendant un certain laps de
temps en temps très limité oui et je
crois surtout qu'elle n'engage au rien
l'avenir du jeune homme qui reçoit ces
injections physiologiquement ces
injections d'hormones ne vous ont
apporté aucun trouble
et psychologiquement
au stade où nous en sommes nous voulions
atteindre un certain but disons que ça
nous a aidé ça nous a viré certains
complexes
[Musique]
docteur Escobar
il y avait des mineurs
certains m'ont présenté spontanément
leur carte d'identité pour me prouver
qu'ils étaient majeurs il n'est pas dans
les habitudes médicales de demander des
candidats d'entités aux gens lorsqu'ils
ont l'air majeurs vous ne pouviez pas
vous en rendre compte selon leur
apparence physique s'ils étaient mineurs
ou majeures
[Musique]
des associations et c'est bien de venir
en aide à ces inadaptée mais les choses
ne sont pas aussi simples qu'elles le
paraissent le docteur Sedan représentant
le conseil d'administration de
l'Association pour la réadaptation
sociale ainsi que les responsables
éducateurs de l'établissement Le casque
à relais précise quels sont les buts de
cette association le conseil
d'administration de l'association tient
à rappeler que son seul but le seul but
de l'association et devrait pour la
réadaptation et la réinsertion sociale
des mineurs inadaptés qui lui sont
confiés pour la plupart par la justice
indiscutablement certaines je dis bien
certaine
intervention médicale
contribuant à installer sans espoir de
retour
des adolescents mineurs et j'insiste sur
mineur dans la prostitution ont été
combattues par la société alors quelles
sont ces certaines interventions madame
c'est un problème extrêmement compliqué
parce que je suis médecin vous attendez
à ce que je vous donne des réponses
précises je ne suis hélas que
neurochirurgien et d'autres médecins et
le docteur Geller en particulier ont des
opinions parce qu'ils sont
endocrinologues beaucoup plus solides
que la mienne
je ne peux pas vous répondre sur ce
problème nous savons simplement que
chaque cas est particulier et qu'il est
indiscutablement des actions médicales
pas forcément uniquement d'injection
d'hormones qui peuvent nuire à la
réadaptation sociale des enfants mineurs
qui sont confiés à l'association
alors quel est votre position face au
docteur Elise salam de la Chaume qui est
la prescrit des injections d'hormones je
ne me permettrai pas Madame d'avoir la
moindre opposition à ce sujet devant la
complexité de ce sujet je n'ai jamais
adressé personne à un service
chirurgical ni même une officine ou leur
faisait des injections ils à l'aide où
il voulait ils ont leur chirurgien
esthétique pas seulement pour
des interventions
avisées castratrice mais souvent pour
des histoires d'esthétiques de nez etc
est-ce que vous avez envisagé alors
véritablement la transexualité c'est à
dire l'intervention chirurgicale
c'est là que je ne suis pas d'accord
avec tout ce qui a été dit en ce moment
on est transexuel
on ne se fait pas opérer pour devenir
transexuel
on se fait opérer
pour atteindre notre équilibre parfait
obtenir l'identité civile
et pour voir pour pouvoir vivre
une vie normale une vie normale parce
que moralement nous sommes femmes
physiquement pas encore tout à fait je
leur ai d'un certain cas prescrits de
poursuivre leur traitement hormonal
parce que je pensais que
psychologiquement c'était dangereux de
leur refuser alors que je leur refusais
déjà bien d'autres choses
est-ce que
vous avez été quelquefois tenté par la
drogue
pour dire vrai oui
j'étais
de ça grâce à Madame Salem vous ne vivez
toutes que de la prostitution
moi j'ai travaillé en cabaret et puis je
suis arrivé à Marseille et
[Musique]
ma toxicomanie m'a obligé à reprendre la
prostitution
mais croyez-moi ce n'est pas un idéal
pour nous loin de là
je comprends très bien ce que vous avez
essayé de vous sortir de la prostitution
justement
[Musique]
qu'un patron nous prendrez même si le
patron nous prend 3 jours après est
obligé de nous mettre à la porte le
personnel la clientèle personne ne nous
accepterait et surtout maintenant après
ce scandale on parle de traite des
blancs commencez-vous sont-ils soutenus
non enfin à mon avis à mon avis ce
qu'ils m'ont dit si nous étions soutenus
si on nous finançait si on nous
protégeait protéger oui je crois que
c'est important nous serions moins
agressés que nous ne sommes or ils le
sont dans leur intégrité physique il y a
des automobilistes qui n'hésitent pas à
foncer
j'ai eu un malade qui a été qui a eu les
deux jambes cassées par un automobiliste
qui lui a foncé dessus en voiture
jusqu'à présent les travestis ça pouvait
être un amusement maintenant on vient
voir les travestis parce que ce sont
comme on dit les journaux des bêtes
et pour les insulter notre Conseil tient
à affirmer que s'il s'est félicite et
c'est vrai de savoir l'opinion publique
sensibilisée aux situations dramatiques
qui concernent les jeunes qui sont
confiés entre autres à l'association
pour la réputation sociale depuis des
années il déploque que ce soit trop
souvent par le tranchant par le
truchement du scandale et du
spectaculaire l'ordre des médecins dans
un cas particulier comme celui-ci n'a
pas à se prononcer
l'ordre est un organisme juridictionnel
qui ne peut se prononcer que lorsqu'il
est saisi d'une plainte
heure que je sache l'ordre n'a pas été
directement
informé d'une plainte sur ce sujet qui
lui soit parvenu mais puisqu'il y a eu
plein de au niveau de la justice il est
concevable que la justice demande son
avis à l'ordre qui à ce moment-là je le
pense le donnera
[Musique]
une démarche est encore possible si elle
est profondément voulue ces hommes qui
tendent à devenir des femmes doivent
savoir qu'ils peuvent un jour redevenir
des hommes normaux
je pense qu'il y a aucun problème c'est
égal les injections trop répétées ne
laissent aucune séquelles même physique
[Musique]
peut-être
garderont-ils une gynécomastie pendant
un certain temps c'est possible mais ça
n'affectera en rien je pense leur
capacité virile si c'est tenté ce que
l'on veut obtenir aucun inconvénient
physiologique aucun inconvénient
psychologique
je ne pense pas que ça influence
tellement le psychisme le psychisme
existe avant c'est leur problème
moralement docteur vous avez le
sentiment d'avoir fait votre devoir
moralement oui
c'est pas toujours facile il faut
assumer certaines responsabilités
voilà à vous maintenant de juger
quant à nous en essayant de vous
informer nous voulions surtout susciter
la réflexion et espérer peut-être que
ces transsexuels objets de curiosité et
de dérision ne provoque plus la haine ou
la vengeance ceux qui malheureusement
sont hors de la norme devraient
bénéficier de notre compréhension sinon
de notre aide
[Musique]